Suppose there is a fence erected in the
middle of nowhere that's blocking your
path what do you do do you take it down
in order to continue on your way or do
you first think hard about why it is
there to begin with
[Music]
chesterton's fence is a simple rule of
thumb that suggests that you should
never destroy a fence change a rule or
do away with a tradition until you
understand why it's there in the first
place
the principal assumes that fences have a
purpose were carefully planned and cost
time and money to erect someone must
have had a reason for thinking that
offense would be a good idea so what if
we just take them down
entrepreneur Steve blank likes to point
out that when startups get their first
Chief Financial Officer the newly hired
often wants to show that they are
proactive and can cut costs some go as
far as calculating the expense of the
free snacks offered to employees and
then start charging the staff a small
fee
people can of course pay but they don't
like this change in company culture and
many May quit as a result The Firm makes
Pennies on the nuts but spends thousands
hiring new Engineers all because the
reformer didn't understand the purpose
of the policy he axed
a more tragic example of misguided
reform was China's so-called Great Leap
Forward which lasted from 1958 to 1962.
one of its initiatives was the four
pests campaign to eliminate all
mosquitoes flies rats and even sparrows
that were suspected of stealing grain
from the fields
and so millions of people hit noisy pots
and pans to prevent sparrows from
resting with the goal of causing them to
drop dead from exhaustion
some simply shot the birds down from the
sky others destroyed their nests and
broke their eggs
the campaign worked and pushed the
Chinese Sparrow population to near
Extinction so what about the unintended
consequences
with no sparrows to eat them Locust
populations ballooned swarming the
country and compounding the problems
caused by other reforms the consequence
was the great Chinese famine one of the
largest man-made disasters in human
history with a death toll in the tens of
Millions
perhaps all those who want to break with
Traditions or reform Norms should learn
to recite this short line from
philosopher F K chesterton's original
1929 writing
in the matter of reforming things as
distinct from deforming them there is
one plain and simple principle
let us say for the sake of Simplicity a
fence or gait is erected across a road
the more modern type of reformer goes up
to it and says I don't see the use of
this let us clear it away to which the
more intelligent type of reformer will
do well to answer if you don't see the
use of it I certainly won't let you
clear it away go away and think then
when you can come back and tell me that
you do see the use of it I may allow you
to destroy it
what do you think is chesterton's
defensive conservatism A good rule to
live by or do you also need people to
break down old structures even if they
don't fully understand why they were
built in the first place
share your thoughts in the comments
below
foreign
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities